[موسيقى]
تعرفت على الاصابه بالمطبخ بلشت العب
باصوات مثل ما ولد كل ولد صغير بيلعب كنت
انطر اهلي ليفلوا من البيت نجيب المرتبين
حط فيهم مستوى معين من الماء جرب العب مع
الوقت
لعبتي صارت اكبر واكبر والعيله بالمطبخ
كبرت كانت اللغه اكثر بالايدين من الكلام
[موسيقى]
اهل شافوا انه هذا الشيء مش مقبول فصار في
شويه مشاكل فكره انه ابنن راح يلعب
ايقاع هذا مستقبله كان في خوف
[موسيقى]
وقت رفضوا اهلي سجلوا بالكونسرفتوار قررت
تفتش على شغل لقيت نجار بلشت شغل بعد
ثلاثه اشهر بروح النجار لعند اهلي بركب
خزانه بالبيت بيقول لي بعتذر ما كان مصاري
اعطيك اجرك فعمل له الخزانه لاهلك البيت
نطرت للصيفيه اللي بعدها
واشتغلت وسجلت
وانطلقت
[موسيقى]
عملت اكثر من عمل مع منظمه الامم المتحده
مع جمعيه مارش بلبنان والهدف منها كان ان
كل ولد يكتشف حاله موسيقيا بلا ولا اله
كيف يعبر بجسمه عن الموسيقى كيف في عبر
بطنجر عن الموسيقى كيف يشوف الموسيقى وين
ما كان
بعتقد كل حدا عنده قصه يخبرها وكل حدا
موجود بهذه الحياه كرمال القصه احلى شيء
اذا بيقدر يحطها
بلحن او بارفاع او باي نوع ثاني
[موسيقى]